без російських лики у двуличний малюк
нам уже вбиті з опини гумати вікторія
піщаній косі криму та початку ризикових
де на донбасі
он з циклу з аптек і батьківщина ви машина
їздить через неврологічні препарати
в росію біля латини кортексин c
витяжка скажи головному мозку
ікла рогатих зручних маєтку людині зі
швидкої їзди до білгорода за ним але в нього
не було в ту годину вилиці треба було і
міністр але ж я не може видно ось з
цим з купою проблем з російською чи до
ми ви на клуби на тему українців а леді
кому вдалося, а знаєте їм заміну
наличия його дорівнює твій найкращий клієнт
янкул і хочеш і доріжки червона киснеш а
я тут у світі erwinia капустина куб у
та плати епілептичні препарати для
своєю данькою ну ось ми доставлені можна
було в Україні знає even potluck про
саміт терміналу
нам довелося ієгуді 100 ват із польші
чим краще на прокиньте 2015 уроку
не було озеро і суворо на травні ж
250 російських препаратів алое їхньої машини
спустошують на вимкнена що на за баром
он і повністю знак ніч за птахів стрибай
вниз пропустити його війська за барона на
базами російських лики в Україні до
уряду згорнувся в ікону че повістці
міністра оборони здоров'я
ulyana супрун а.в. вона не прахова
політичного контексту такого рішення
справжніх стандартів бутану з вина
Країна я корозія за лавину проти
українського народу на травня права за рублі
то на нашому доказі ванні
головні дитя дж і йому нових ти його
фірмової що уста точно видно виду
російських liceul але я катастрофа you
are just вони ледве руках окрузі не
вдалося і за хвилини та чисельним роботи
Наземні канали мамі єдину в гостру
проблему завищується особа є в Україні
магічних сирого струм річки багата руки
постукала наша russia
цех з шуму води про так звання
імуноглобуліни а намисто robotki проти 3
pro ти правда про табу туризму проти
оповіді нас на з засмучений ниць і спрацювання
дружини вирубні кролики і в свічки а ви не
допустіть смертельних випадків поважаючи
liqueur уряд і верховна рада маю
термінал hd 3d закуповує ці препарати
пацієнти вже їли дискусія заміну
курон здоров'я уступ міраж і просять
наук вали ось і непродуманих рішень
вікторія оголошувати ей отис непомітні
коли прийнятими ціна ми не готова
жертвувати здоров'ям сина за рада
політикою та їздцям і
за ликом eurostil